[Music]
this episode and others like it are made
possible by the generous support of my
patrons on patreon
if you'd like to help me produce more
content like this and get early access
to every new video consider becoming a
patron at patreon.com
second thought you'll often hear the
claim that the united states is the
freest place on earth
a bastion of personal and societal
freedom for such a supposedly free
nation we sure have a lot of people
behind bars
while many rights and freedoms have been
stripped away over the past few decades
from freedom of the press to freedom
of assembly in this video we're going to
focus specifically on the u.s prison
system
a system that by just about every metric
is the worst in the developed world
let's start with some basic facts the us
has the most incarcerated people of any
nation on earth
both by sheer numbers and per capita as
of june 2020
there were 2 million 121 000 prisoners
currently serving time in the u.s
and a total of over 10 million in the
prison system which includes those
waiting for trial and those on parole
this number is higher than nations with
vastly larger populations like china and
india
it's higher than countries the u.s
considers more authoritarian like russia
or again
china it's even higher than the greatest
of all boogeymen the soviet union at the
height of stalin's power
as for our per capita rating the u.s
incarcerates roughly 655 people per 100
thousand
no other oecd nation comes close the uk
sits at 140
canada 107 france 105 germany 77
china barely cracks 150. all the
countries the u.s likes to cast as
authoritarian hellholes
every single one of them incarcerates
fewer people and often in far more
humane facilities
the u.s represents four percent of the
total world population
but 22 percent of the world's prison
population when you talk about prison
and prisoners
all the racists tend to come out of the
woodwork and say things like well those
other places are all one race
and immigrants are just inherently
criminal of course these statements have
no basis in reality
among roughly equally diverse nations
and countries with similarly sized
immigrant populations
our incarceration rate is still vastly
higher in every case
we also need to remind these people that
white people go to jail too
they're just let off the hook far more
frequently than any other race
but we'll get to that later now that you
have an idea of just how much of an
obsession we have with locking people up
let's talk about some specifics if
you're familiar with my channel
you'll know that i identify one common
thread that ties together all of the
worst tendencies of the american empire
profit everything is driven by the
insatiable urge to accumulate greater
and greater sums of money
the stock market demands perpetual
growth corporations must make more
this year than they did last year the
prison industrial complex is no
different
we tend to think of prisons as
self-contained entities cruel
but untainted by the tendrils of
capitalism this is not the case
companies have always been eager to work
with prisons to increase their profits
the companies that provide food to
prisoners are only too happy to sell
nutritionally deficient slop to the
prison industrial complex
it's cheap to produce and nets them a
healthy profit the phone companies that
provide basic call functionality to
prisoners charge exorbitant
pay-per-minute rates because they know
how desperate these poor people are to
speak to their loved ones
transportation companies make a killing
shuttling prisoners to and from court
appearances and between prisons
but more egregious than these examples
is the practice of modern day slavery
you've probably heard that the state of
california routinely puts inmates to
work fighting fires
do you know what they're paid for
putting their lives on the line
two dollars per day or two dollars per
hour when they're actively fighting
fires
the minimum wage in the us is 7.25 per
hour
which is already absurdly low and has
been determined not to be a livable wage
prisoners are paid two dollars per hour
at best for their labor
less than one third of the federal
minimum wage but wait it gets worse
incarcerated people have their own
minimum wage care to guess what it is
it's not two dollars it's 12 cents per
hour
some states including my home state of
texas do not require incarcerated
workers to be paid at all would you sell
an hour of your life for 12 cents
of course you wouldn't but the people
trapped in the prison system have no
choice in the matter
they are required to do the work that is
demanded of them
this is slavery in the past year inmates
have been put to work manufacturing hand
sanitizer and ppe
washing hospital laundry and digging
mass graves for covid victims
in normal years they provide forced
labor for thousands of us corporations
including big names like mcdonald's
wendy's tyson
verizon sprint fidelity walmart jcpenney
and ibm
angry yet it still gets worse with each
passing year
america finds new ways to extract
profits from human life
let's talk about private prisons as the
war on drugs ramped up in the 1980s
federal prisons began to become
overcrowded the solution
turned to the private sector to build
new prisons for all this excess human
inventory
the government contracts a private
company to build the prisons that
company locks up the overflow prisoners
and in exchange they receive a fixed
rate for each inmate
they are paid for each person they
imprison
see the problem here the prison slave
labor market is a financial incentive
not to pursue prison reform
it would damage the profits of thousands
of u.s companies but by adding
for-profit prisons into the mix
cutting out the middleman and simply
making money off of human storage units
we've ensured that no meaningful reform
will ever pass
at least not without a mass movement to
demand it think about it who profits
from the existence of private prisons
private companies are given
multi-hundred million dollar contracts
then their executives turn around and
donate huge sums of that same money to
politicians who will support private
prisons
it's a never-ending cycle corrupt
politicians are making money
private prisons are making money and
thousands of u.s companies are making
money from literal slave labor
it makes perfect sense within the u.s
capitalist framework
core civic formerly corrections
corporation of america
is the largest private prison manager in
the country in 2019 they raked in 1.98
billion dollars in revenue
all on the backs of exploited human
beings stuffed into their prisons with a
price tag on each one
what's even more ridiculous is that the
vast majority of the private prison
contracts contain a lock-up quota
that is a guaranteed percentage of
occupancy for the duration of the
agreement
most of these quotas are set at 90
occupancy with some even landing an
insane 100 percent
so in a time when crime rates are the
lowest they've been in decades
these private prisons are guaranteed to
have their cells filled
if those cells aren't filled they're
still paid as if they were
and guess who pays the bill u.s
taxpayers
there was one hideous incident in 2008
which became known as the kids for cash
scandal
two judges in luzerne county
pennsylvania were found to have been
accepting bribes from for-profit
correctional facilities to dole out
ridiculously harsh sentences for minors
thousands of children were slapped with
extended stays in these private
facilities
for crimes as minor as making fun of
their assistant principal on myspace
there are few things more depraved than
putting innocent children in jail to
line your own pocket
so to recap the u.s started the war on
drugs
drugs which u.s groups like the cia were
shuttling into the country
began locking people up at unprecedented
rates for non-violent drug offenses
realized we had literally run out of all
of our prison space
and decided to contract out private
companies in order to lock up more
people
and then paid those companies to
incarcerate even more people
this system is absurd by any reasonable
estimation
and we still haven't even discussed
whether or not it's effective
to make a long story short no it's not
effective
in the united states we focus more on
punishment than rehabilitation
and u.s prisons are certainly punishment
in fact they're so
inhumane that the united nations has
condemned them as abusive and torturous
and human rights organizations have long
asserted that one of the prison
industrial complex's favorite tools
solitary confinement is literal torture
once someone has been released from
prison it's much harder to find a job
and two out of three end up right back
in a cell because their situation is so
desperate
we've even seen people commit tiny
crimes and purposefully get arrested
because then at least they'd have a roof
over their heads
when many americans hear this they'll
shake their heads and say you just can't
fix some people
completely ignoring the fact that our
prison system is not intended to fix
anything
again this fits in perfectly with the
average american mindset
most people subjected to prison terms
are poor in america
we've been conditioned to believe that
poor people are lazy and therefore
morally deficient and deserving of
punishment
this of course ignores the fact that
wealthy people are just as likely or
even more likely to use drugs
but those people are rarely sentenced
often because they have important
parents or they can pay bail or simply
because their communities aren't heavily
policed like lower income areas
we've effectively criminalized poverty
can't pay a parking ticket
jail can't pay bail prison term no one
will hire you when you get out
serves you right for being a criminal
this mindset is truly horrific
it lacks even the barest shred of basic
human decency
we cannot ignore the fact that systemic
racism plays a large role in the
american prison system
two men one white and one black charged
for the same crime with the same
criminal background
are often given different length prison
sentences can you guess who gets the
longer sentence
on average black people are given 20
longer sentences for the same crime
committed by a white person
then you have white collar crime banks
have engaged in money laundering for
drug cartels and other shady operations
for years
bankrolling the very industry we throw
people away for and they caused the
single largest economic crash since the
great depression
did any bankers get locked up for any
significant time of course not
there are two separate justice systems
in this country one for the rich
and one for everyone else okay but
what's the alternative
it's not fair to complain and then not
propose a better way luckily for me
i don't have to come up with an entirely
new system plenty of vastly more humane
more modern and more effective prison
systems already exist
one shining example is norway with an
incarceration rate of just 60 per 100
thousand
norway stands out as a prime example
after which we could model our own
prison system
norway's criminal justice system focuses
not on punishment like we do in the u.s
but on rehabilitation and the principle
of restorative justice
the norwegian criminal justice system
caps prison sentences at 21 years and
does not allow the death penalty
whereas prisons in the u.s look more or
less like slightly updated medieval
dungeons
norwegian prisons are quite different
this footage is from halden prison which
was completed in 2010 and is
representative of norway's incarceration
philosophy
everything is intended to foster an
environment of improvement for their
inmates
the rooms are reasonably comfortable and
furnished with quality of life features
like dvd players and tvs
the inmates can roam more or less freely
wear normal clothes
and make use of common areas and
kitchens there's a store where they can
buy their own food
the architecture is specifically
designed to allow those inside to see
out into nature and observe the passage
of time
u.s prisons by contrast are made as
oppressive as possible
little light from the outside world
cramped corridors tiny uncomfortable
cells and a relationship with the guards
which can only be called antagonistic
that's another area where norwegian
prisons excel their correctional
officers all complete a two-year degree
before they're able to work as what are
called contact officers
which function as both guard and social
worker holden prison prides itself on
fostering excellent interpersonal
relationships between inmates and
contact officers
they can interact freely talk play cards
make plans for the future
and just generally have a normal human
experience in the prison
this is all part of the philosophy of
normality the idea is to make prison as
close to life in the outside world as
possible so that when inmates have
served their time they're able to more
easily adjust back to normal life
again this is in stark contrast to the
us system the goal of our system is to
punish
to make people suffer so that they're
afraid to commit another crime
corrections officers in the u.s have
very little required training
and relationships between guards and
prisoners are truly awful
it's not uncommon for guards to
brutalize or sexually assault the
inmates
this cruelty is completely
counterproductive if the goal of our
prisons was truly to rehabilitate
why have the guards the only
representatives from the outside world
treat the inmates like animals norway's
recidivism rates are among the lowest in
the world
with just 20 percent of inmates getting
arrested again within two years
this isn't random it came about by a
concerted effort from norwegian citizens
to overhaul their criminal justice
system
back in the 80s and 90s they were
concerned about rising recidivism rates
so they did the logical thing and fixed
the problem the prisons
modern norwegian prisons are some of the
very best in the world in terms of
reducing recidivism and promoting a
positive trajectory for inmates
they provide counseling education and as
normal an experience as possible
what they've accomplished in the last
few decades is truly remarkable
and should be seen as one of the world's
best criminal justice systems
another prime example is finland finland
is one of the happiest and safest
countries in the world
they have access to universal healthcare
subsidized child care
and free college education they also
have incredibly humane prisons
this man serving a life sentence for
murder is not confined to a tiny cell
for the rest of his life
he's not waiting for a lethal injection
or months of solitary confinement
he is free to come and go as he pleases
and there aren't any cell blocks at all
instead the prison is laid out like a
dormitory he can attend classes at the
local university
and his room at loca prison is almost
indistinguishable from a normal
apartment
like norway finland believes in the
principle of normality
that prisoners should be treated like
human beings and provided all the
opportunities to improve themselves and
get on a more productive path during
their prison stay
inmates receive counseling job training
and interact with prison staff in a
normal human fashion
because of these innovations and a
dedication to actual rehabilitation
finland's incarceration rate has dropped
dramatically over the last 70 years
to just one quarter of what it was in
1950 and it's now one of the lowest in
europe
by comparison the us prison population
has skyrocketed in that same period
despite our own crime rate dropping just
to give you a sense of how barbaric and
outdated our prison system seems to
other developed nations
finland now operates a prison museum in
one of their old 19th century prisons
as a sort of reminder of how terrible
their system used to be
it is almost indistinguishable from a
modern u.s prison
it's clear that the u.s has a long way
to go before it can be considered a
truly free nation
our horrific prison industrial complex
is a permanent stain on this country's
legacy
the systemic racism use of slave labor
inhumane treatment and outright torture
of prisoners
and the commodification of human lives
to be locked up in order to increase
profits
is truly wrong in every way if we're
actually angered by this
and really want to make a change we have
positive examples to point to and say
this is what we want it won't happen by
itself
the only way things will change is the
only way things have ever changed
by enough people coming together to say
enough is enough
we're trying something new
i mentioned at the beginning of this
video that this kind of content is made
possible by my patrons on patreon
this sort of video while very important
is something that sponsors won't touch
in order to pay the bills and keep this
channel running i rely on adsense
revenue sponsors and donations from
generous viewers by producing explicitly
anti-capitalist content
i lose out on both sponsors and adsense
if you enjoy the kind of videos i'm
producing and you're able to chip in
even a dollar a month i would greatly
appreciate the support
you can find my patreon page join our
growing discord server and get early
access to every episode at patreon.com
second thought
if you enjoyed this video consider
dropping a like if you hated it a thumbs
down
you can check out my previous episodes
by clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching
and i'll see you next week
[Music]
you